we have to start today with russia and
ukraine where there are both reasons to
be
uh absolutely horrified about what may
be coming to the planet over the next
several weeks but also some reasons to
be cautiously optimistic and we're going
to talk about both and we should
understand both
on the one hand the bad
we are facing what kamala harris calls a
real possibility
of what boris johnson refers to as the
biggest european war since world war ii
we have no reason to believe at this
point
that russia and putin were telling the
truth about pulling back with there has
not been any independently verified
evidence that suggests that's what's
taking place despite the claims last
week and there is reason to believe
according to president joe biden
that vladimir putin has already made the
decision
to invade ukraine
now i don't know if we need to
refresh the entire situation
but
russia points to so-called nato
expansion and support of ukraine from
nato as an act of aggression
the
actual aggressor in the case of russia
and ukraine
is clearly putin but there are some who
say his aggression is justified and this
includes
i mean in the u.s some on the right and
some on the left for different reasons
many of them victims of different types
of propaganda which we will talk about
but let's go to some of what world
leaders are saying and it doesn't really
matter
whether you like these world leaders i
don't particularly love either of them
um but let's talk about what is being
said
here is a
british prime minister
boris johnson take a listen the plan
that we're seeing
is for something that could be really
the biggest war in europe since 1945 and
just in terms of sheer scale
you're looking at um
not just an invasion through the east
through the through the donbass but uh
according to the intelligence
intelligence that we're seeing coming
down from the north down from belarus
and actually encircling uh kiev itself
as yes so what it's
it is the type of thing
that
the circumstances are completely
different than world war ii but in terms
of the scale
in european countries it would be if
it's the worst case scenario
clearly the biggest war in europe since
world war ii kamala harris also
commenting on this from the munich
security conference over the weekend i
mean listen guys
we're talking about the potential for
war in europe
i mean let's really take a moment to
understand the significance of what
we're talking about
it's been over 70 years
and through those 70 years as i
mentioned yesterday there has been peace
and security
we are talking about the real
possibility of war in europe now there
has not been total peace and security in
europe and we have had a number of
different uh civil wars within europe
and oh okay but the the point is clear
which is this type of
large war involving multiple countries
has not been seen in europe since world
war ii
so our position
is for us very clear
which is as a leader which we have been
bringing together the allies
working together
around our collective and unified
position
that we would
all not just prefer we desire we believe
it is in the best interest of all
that there is a diplomatic end now
unfortunately
um
foreign diplomacy is not kamala harris's
area of expertise but it actually is joe
biden's to a great degree and we're
going to talk about that in this in the
next segment but if this were to happen
and i hope it doesn't i don't want a war
i don't want u.s troops in ukraine i
don't i don't i don't want any of it
okay
this would be disastrous
even for americans in so many different
ways like we talk about supply chain
issues just you wait now you might say
well david sir we don't really get stuff
from russia no that's true but much of
europe's energy comes from russia and if
you see
this conflict escalate it would be
economically devastating for russia for
sure because they would likely stop
getting a ton of that econo european
money they depend on
but europe would have energy issues
those energy issues will translate into
supply chain issues and it's going to be
bad for the supply chain issues we've
been experiencing here energy pricing
issues just you wait if you're upset
about gas prices right now
chaos in the stock markets everyone's
401ks retirement accounts it is going to
be insanity and i hope it doesn't happen
now what is the hope well the hope is
that putin realizes even though europe
depends on his energy that he depends on
europe's money
and that he realizes the economic cost
will be incredibly high the only problem
is that putin
in order to maintain his authoritarian
strongman
sort of uh delusion
he has placed himself in a tough
situation if he does invade it is very
clear the costs are going to be massive
the cost will be massive elsewhere in
the world too we will suffer too but on
the one hand if putin does invade the
costs are going to be massive on the
other hand is he does if he doesn't does
he look weak
so
uh that is where the biden negotiations
that may be coming together will be
interesting and i'll talk about that in
a moment in terms of domestic politics
in the u.s the republican party seems to
trust putin more than our own
intelligence services and it doesn't
mean our intelligence services haven't
been wrong in the past or haven't done
bad things they've been wrong and
they've done bad things
but
the republican party increasingly seems
to be the party of putin which is
bizarre
we also need to stop perpetuating the
falsehood that russia hasn't really done
anything with ukraine yet i mean
remember russia invaded ukraine when
they took crimea
they're effectively occupying eastern uk
ukraine via proxies uh in a couple of
areas
and when they did the crimean annexation
the u.s and most of the world said that
was really bad that you did that uh but
after after you know saying that it was
basically allowed to happen i'm not
advocating that it should have been time
to bomb russia or i'm just saying that
happened and here's one of the most
important things
we need to
get more exposure
to the reality that there's a russian
propaganda campaign that's fracturing
the united states politically and it is
designed to if russia were to invade
ukraine fully tomorrow whatever that
means in the end
you would see
a huge portion of the online us
appear to support russia you would see a
lot of it and
there would likely be the follow-on
effect
that
republicans in congress will oppose
anything joe biden does not necessarily
because all of them support russia
although i think a bunch of them do and
they don't even really understand why
but because republicans are unified in
trying to prevent joe biden from doing
anything and they see it as a pathway to
returning to power so this is a
dangerous combination russia runs
propaganda campaigns to make many on the
american right and and many on the left
default to or support vladimir putin or
at least stop short of criticizing him
and this will have the effect of
emboldening republicans
to continue opposing and trying to block
anything joe biden wants to do even if
what joe biden wants to do is stop a war
between russia and ukraine and so that's
what we're going to talk about next as
someone who watches youtube you know how
annoying it is to watch ads at the
beginning of videos that are completely
irrelevant to the content you're
watching that's why you always click the
skip ad button our sponsor thought
leaders has just launched a new
targeting tool that allows advertisers
to choose the precise videos where their
ads will appear using the advanced
search in the thought leaders platform
which is powered by ai you can actually
find youtube videos relevant to your
brand's messaging and with thought
leaders precision targeting you can
really make every view count optimize
your ad spend improve your conversions
when brands put their ads on relevant
videos they catch their audience when
they are most receptive and create a
more fulfilling enjoyable youtube
experience for everyone involved plans
start at just 60 a month but you can try
it now for just thirty dollars for the
first month when you click the link
below and use the code pacman at
checkout